he has had this position before so maybe
the surprise wasn't this
this position which isn't new to him but
the surprise was that magnus carson is
repeating it
and that is all psychology at play look
how much time it's cost nakamura this
one move
six and a half minutes now and he's
still looking down
trying to remember things he just needs
to play the position afresh
um completely reset look we're getting
that variation
i showed on the board a few moments ago
nakamura
he found his courage he allowed this
sacrifice
magnus carson going on the attack now
giving up a bishop
for a couple of pawns in order to
explode the position
explode black's king structure wow this
is
really heating up but nakamura i thought
he would spend all that time and maybe
play a safety first move
he spent all that time and said i'm
calling your bluff magnus you sacrificed
the peace
i'm going to defend and will we see that
backfire
magnus look at the clock situation
magnus says gain time he's gained one
and a half minutes
for sure he has studied this actually
this morning
and um that's very brave by nakamura to
allow it
no i mean uh totally braved i mean
i'm really shocked actually that this
has been allowed on the board it looks
oh horrible i mean just look at look at
the bar that's all the way
to the side white is winning and not
just in one way right now
i think magnus has a deadly attack
nakamura spent all that time in a
position he already knew
and he's just played a losing move we
have to bring up the analysis board
let's keep an eye on the players because
we might see a reaction
from nakamura but in this current
position black has just brought his
bishop out to this square
it looks like he's going to use this
bishop to defend on this square
maybe he'll drop it back the whole way
to defend his king but
magnus just bring pieces into the attack
we see magnus frowning
he studied it this morning he did not
study this move which shows